The electric light, the
telephone, the microchip.
All great inventions.
But for me, the most
important of all
was the wheel, mainly because
it led to things like this.
Downhill cycling.
Why use two wheels when one
makes you look twice as cool?
But before you even think about
pulling off a downhill wheelie,
be aware that even
on two wheels,
it could still be perilous.
What makes downhill cycling
is such a terrifying pursuit
is that the bike isn't only
powered by the cyclist's legs,
but also by our
old friend gravity.
When a cyclist goes up a
hill, he gradually gains
gravitational potential energy.
When he descends, this
gravitational potential energy
can be converted over a
very short period of time
into a terrifying amount
of kinetic energy.
If the rider falls, that kinetic
energy might be converted
into heat via friction,
or if they stop suddenly,
dissipated via deformation.
So energy is never destroyed.
It's merely transferred
into something else
like kinetic energy,
heat, or even the sound
of an impact, which
is often accompanied
by the sound of screaming.
To investigate, we sent
out some of our more
reckless researchers.
This guy has made
a deal with gravity
and built up a lot
of kinetic energy.
So much so that he's
able to pass cars.
Except that one.
The cyclist is
unable to transfer
enough kinetic energy into heat
the friction at its brakes.
When he hits the car, his
remaining kinetic energy
is transferred into sound, heat,
and dissipated a deformation,
also known as bouncing off.
Don't worry.
He was OK.
All right.
Let's try a gentler pace.
This is more like it.
A chance to take in the scenery.
And his friend's bottom.
He appears to make no attempt
to reduce his kinetic energy.
And his linear momentum
becomes angular momentum
as he rotates around the
axle of the front wheel.
And maybe not the last.
Perhaps it's safer to
go downhill on three
wheels with these drift trikes.
Or maybe not.
It's just as well our
drift trike gang are
heading home on four wheels.
Maybe safer just to walk.